I almost feel like this has been called
Catalina pre lewd maybe overture would
be more appropriate
Castlevania on Netflix is out I was so
pumped for this thing I it's one of the
iddah no it is pretty much the only PU
game-related adaptation that I've had
excitement for since soon well since
I've been an adult this was a big deal
for me because I loved Castlevania games
I love the look of this thing cause it
reminded me great he loved it by 100 II
which I love I love Warren Ellis who's
writing it I like the voice cast Adi
Shankar who's producing it I find him a
guy worth following with what he's up to
so I want to do this with pretty high
expectations that didn't quite get met
but maybe I was expecting too much for
this first go I don't think I knew
before actually sitting down to watch it
that it was only four episodes and they
were 22 minutes apiece I think if I had
known that earlier on and that
information might have been out there I
maybe I just didn't track it down
because I was trying to avoid spoilers
but if I known that sooner I might have
adjusted my expectations to what this
actually is which is not really
Castlevania the series it is Castlevania
the prologue so it really is just
setting up the situation the threat the
players and that's it by the end of the
fourth episode everything has been set
up for the actual storming of Dracula's
castle to begin now I'm sure some people
are going why don't you put up a spoiler
warning for that because I don't
consider it a spoiler to tell people
that something that they might have been
thinking was going to be coming is not
going to be here now things already been
renewed for a second season so we should
we're going to get what I think a lot of
us came in here hoping to get this time
around so it's coming but it's not this
so you know if you consider that a
spoiler fine consider that a spoiler and
I'm sorry but I think I wish somebody
giving me the heads-up to adjust my my
expectations because once I get myself
the headspace above this thing actually
is it's good it is pretty darn good I
love the style of how gothic it is I
love the creature designs the action
when it happens and this show is not a
wall-to-wall action certainly not in
these early days at any rate but when
the action scenes happen they're really
good they hit hard
they are gory and just that the impact
hurt and we get a couple of really good
fight sequences we get a couple with
humans we get one really good one with a
with a monster and there's some other
monster action later on and it's all
yeah it's a lot of fun cast is pretty
solid too the main one that I came away
really liking I think it's important
that I like him is Trevor Belmont who is
voiced by Richard Armitage and I think
he definitely does a really good job of
doing that
you know that reluctant hero thing like
he knows this is his duty it's his
family's legacy but katha doesn't wanna
but he kind of knows he has to you know
it's it's that balance if that
reluctance to get involved and it it's
not exactly groundbreaking it's not
atypical but it is embodied well by the
character and he voices it quite well
I like how much emphasis was pearly on
on us getting basically an understanding
of why Dracula is the threat that he is
and if there's one takeaway from that
first episode especially it should be
never piss off Dracula like ever and we
get a few other characters we get a bit
of history on sort of this nomadic group
of not really religious but they're sort
of they're an order of kind of mystics
called the speakers who are trying to
help we get some background on them one
of their members sort of teams up with
with Trevor and like that we get a look
at you know Dracula himself we get some
time with the character of Lisa who's
pretty important she's not around a long
time but she's pretty important and and
a few other things and I'm not going to
say who else is involved
you look at IMDB you know what other
character show but I think that's the
thing if you anyone familiar with
Castlevania lore is going to call pretty
much everything that's going to happen
that's not that it's like going point
for point with the mythology of the show
it's not a directory creation but if you
look at the cast list on IMDB or
whatever and you know what characters
are showing up you can pretty much
figure out where this thing's going for
these first four of us so it's really
easily doesn't mean it's not fun to
watch it happen and thank goodness too
because if if the action hadn't been
impactful and the characters especially
trevor hadn't been enjoyable to be
around this could have been a real slog
of an opening four episodes and it's not
it doesn't blow me away but it does set
up a setting a world and atmosphere and
characters that I believe could blow me
away in follow-up episodes so it really
does serve as an appetizer for what is
going to come later and as us as a set
up it's a solid setup I am happy with
what I see and I cannot wait for what
comes next
and I wish I knew how long that was
going to be I think it was a good idea
it this is this is well worth binging
just burn through all four episodes that
ago they don't really stand on there I
mean they know they are broken up where
the breaks are makes sense in everything
but it it's about the length of a movie
just burn through it in one go yeah I
think anyone who enjoys gothic anime or
Gala gothic you know stylings and
monsters and settings and is
appreciative of anime style animation is
going to enjoy it I think anyone who
likes Castlevania is going to enjoy just
as I said
temporary our expectations for how far
along this is actually going to get
because this is really just setup this
is just appetizer stuff main course will
be down the road and it it's going to be
pretty tasty if this opening is that is
any indication so those are my thoughts
on Castlevania on Netflix
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available
on iTunes and stitcher I'm also 1/2 of
the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]